the biggest thing that was motivating me
was the potential which hasn't been
taken off very well of people really
think working with their computers
augmenting the human intellect or
boosting the collective IQ with what
computers really could do if we learn
how to integrate their usage into our
own way of thinking how much changed in
human society came about when invention
of writing and then printing and books
and so on each one made a real stage in
the way we learned the way did all kinds
of exchange there like that and so what
the computer can offer is another step
ahead look around at this crowd and you
look at somebody and just instantly it's
a man it's a woman's and what's the
machinery in there that's doing that
nobody questions it point if sweetie
magical here this is hey that's the kind
of way in which knowledge content that
we could be absorbing that and the
computer can be so flexible and how it
shows you things emerges things that why
aren't we really working on
extending our capability